well you've been working with Chancellor
Merkel to try and meet her goal of a
million electric cars on the road on the
road in Germany by 2020 right is that
still a realistic goal that is the
challenging but a goal and we will see
what will be the outcome but we know
that there are three drivers really of
the development and gross for electric
five vehicles which is definitely range
that the customer doesn't have a pain
point in terms of and the infrastructure
and that's something where we need to be
faster in the future to invest more into
the internal structure the city like Los
Angeles where we are here today they are
nearly perfect in many errors but many
parts of Europe's or other countries
across the globe it's difficult to have
the infrastructure and the third pillar
is that we have some attracting pricing
and financial support for the electric
vehicles but I call it also it's a
marathon it's not a sprint and with the
marathon you know that this is being
decided if you win or lose later on
somewhere at kilometer or 30 for example
so you need some time for this movement
and development but it's nothing which
will go away and it's clearly a one
important stripped strategic pillar of
the BMW group to invest into
electrification you I'm sure as a German
as a BMW executive you're a planner what
kind of numbers are you thinking about
you know you're going to develop those
two electric cars you know very soon but
over the next 10 years will you have 10
or 15 new models do you want to make
twenty percent of your sales electric I
mean that's an open point how many
models we will have in the future but if
you think we are now in phase 2 and
phase one we started with the I brand
with I three and I ate now we will
electrify the group portfolio the BMW
brand the MINI brand and we also invest
heavily into the electrified motorcycles
because there's also with urban concepts
of positive future and it will be
difficult to guess how many products we
will offer and how much percentage we
will see in the future but it might
happen that we see a range of maybe
fifteen percent twenty percent
twenty-five percent in the next
years in terms of percentage of
electrified vehicles